MIKE DENNY: Hey, there and
welcome to another episode
of Android design in action.
My name's Mike Denny.
NICK BUTCHER: Hi.
I'm Nick Butcher.
MIKE DENNY: And we also have two
special guests with us today.
MARCO PAGLIA: Hi,
my name is Marco,
I'm an Android designer
here at Google.
ABHILASH KUDUVALLI:
Hey, I'm Abhilash.
I work on the Android
Design team with Marco.
I also have the site
called Android Niceties,
that maybe some of you use.
MIKE DENNY: And we
also have in New York--
ROMAN NURIK: Hey, guys.
Roman Nurik from
New York, as usual.
NICK BUTCHER: So,
Happy New Year.
Welcome to the first
episode this year.
We're going to,
today, cover an update
to the Beautiful
Design Collection,
which is a collection of apps
on Google Play that was updated
just after Christmas,
the end of last year.
And so this is a
collection which
Google Play uses
to showcase some
of the most beautiful
design apps out there,
and is a really, really
good source of inspiration
for looking at apps which
are doing some really, really
great work.
So we'd like to take
the next 20 minutes
or so to take a look
at some of these apps,
and call out some of the
individual design details which
we really enjoyed from them.
And two of the apps from
the previous collection
have stayed in the
collection, so that's
Pinterest and Grand
St., so we're not
going to cover those today.
Feel free to go back to the
previous episode of Android
Design in Action, where
we looked at those.
But we are going to take
a look at the other apps
in the collection.
So without further ado,
we've got a lot of apps
to get through.
We're going to dive straight in.
The first app that we would like
to take a look at is Timely.
So if you're a fan of
Android Design in Action,
you've probably heard us talk
about this a couple of times,
so I'm going to be very
brief with this application,
but essentially it's beautiful.
It really defines
a very high level
of polish and subtle
animations, that just really
showed a lot of thought
went into this application.
So I think, Mike,
you talked about this
in a previous episode.
I think one of your
favorite interactions
is simple things like
setting a timer is
a very, very visceral and
enjoyable interaction.
Things like if I want to set an
alarm, instead of controlling
knobs and levers, I just kind
of swipe out from the edge.
And I can just tap up and down
to finely adjust it, and so on.
Everything is kind of
a direct manipulation
kind of interaction,
which speaks
to some of the
design principles.
It's much more fun to
directly control stuff,
than to control these
knobs and levers.
And again, it's just
polish, polish, polish.
Anyone else have any
thoughts on Timely?
MARCO PAGLIA: Another thing
about this applications
is that you don't
have any [INAUDIBLE].
All the transitions, they go
from one point to another,
I think.
But you heard this
is my favorite,
is how the number zooms
into positions and back,
really, really nicely.
All the things they
have, the transition
between each other,
the interaction
feels a continuous
thing rather than
broken into different screens.
NICK BUTCHER: It's almost
like a game or a movie, right?
In that everything
just kind of seamlessly
transitions between
things, rather than
a series of individual screens.
MARCO PAGLIA: More than
a storyboard, yeah.
MARCO PAGLIA: Right, exactly.
ABHILASH KUDUVALLI: I think even
like when you're counting down
and you're starting a timer,
and each of the seconds
come out as you go
past them, instead
of a little finger or
dial moving past them.
There's lots of little
touches like that,
that are pretty amazing.
MARCO PAGLIA: And we don't
have to forget the transition
across the numbers.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARCO PAGLIA: That's a
pretty cool transition.
It's great that people are
playing with those things.
NICK BUTCHER: Great.
So once again, love the app.
Next up, I think, Roman, you
wanted to take a look at Circa.
ROMAN NURIK: Yes, so Circa is
basically a news reader app,
right.
I think the company
provides its own news,
or they edit their own articles.
But at the heart of it,
it's a news reader app.
It has just a handful of topics.
It's very highly curated.
So the content
itself speaks volumes
about the app and the company.
They're really crafting
the content for, I guess,
almost micro news consumption.
So on top of the visual
awesomeness of the app,
it's very simple.
There's very little
Chrome in the app.
It's really the content,
the images, the photos.
They really stand out,
and the type as well.
Beyond all of that,
there's one thing
that I really wanted
to talk about.
And that's when you look into
or when you open an article,
the way in which you interact
and consume the article
is very novel.
Basically, instead of
just scrolling vertically
through a long list of
paragraphs and images
and things like
that, they actually
take each point-- each
individual point of the news--
and they make that into a
single little card type-thing.
It's a little object, right?
And you flick vertically.
You page vertically between
these individual points.
So consuming the
news is actually
very fun and very quick.
You can flick through to
see what's interesting.
If there's a map or a
photo, it kind of takes up
the majority of the space
in that little point,
in that little card.
And it's really consuming
news at your own pace,
I just really love
the interaction.
Also there's a little
scrubber at the right.
You can scrub along the right
side of that scroll bar thing.
And you can quickly flip through
the different news sections.
So those are my
favorite aspects.
You guys have any other
points about Circa?
MIKE DENNY: Just to
follow up on the point
that you just made about the
digestible scrolling format,
I've actually been staying
up-to-date more on the news
by using Circa thank looking
at news from other sources,
just because it definitely
caters to the skimming
kind of reading where it's
just tiny chunks at a time.
So it's great when
an app actually
changes your day-to-day
where you're more informed.
MIKE DENNY: I also quite
like the information
density they use
on the home screen.
They're unashamedly using
lots of space per story,
rather than trying
to cram in the most
number of stories per screen.
And they also don't present
a ton of stories per day.
So all in all, their
design conveys to me
that they've selected the
most important things,
and these are
important things which
you should pay
attention to and read.
So, like you say, it makes it
very easy to scan a day's news,
and it communicates that
to me for their design.
MARCO PAGLIA: Yes.
One more aspect that
I'd like to have people
look at, which is typography.
So it starts from the
Circa logo itself,
which is just a
typographic logo.
It was also interesting
how, in the main view,
you see the whole logo.
But when you get into
different sources,
they use it differently,
which is really Interesting.
Then obviously you will
recognize this is not
[INAUDIBLE].
And I think applications
that can play with phones
and have different
types of typography
will enrich our platform.
Now obviously
[INAUDIBLE], but it's
good to see other
phones out there.
It's also interesting how they
use words together with icons,
as we do in our platform,
in the action bar.
But even there, they use
a different typography,
which makes this application
feel very distinct.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah,
so we love Circa.
And I think the next app we
want to talk about is Airbnb.
So Airbnb obviously is an
app for the-- it's not really
couch surfing.
The best way to explain it,
if you don't know about Airbnb
already, it's finding traveling
rental, people renting out
properties that they
have for smaller chunks,
as competition to other forms
of travel housing like hotels.
So the thing that
stands out immediately
to me about the Airbnb
app is the use of photos.
And that they're really
utilizing the visual style
of Android, which is to
show full-bleed photos,
so the Chrome kind
of fades away.
It's just about the spaces.
And here we can just tap into a
little bit more detailed view.
But even if you want
to just scroll through,
they have this horizontal
paging within a given property,
so that you don't have
to leave the full list.
This really, really allows for
a simple browsing experience
to find a place that
you want to stay.
MARCO PAGLIA: And
this really speaks
about the philosophy
of Airbnb itself,
which is a company that
had invested tremendously
in design, in particular
had been sending
professional photographers
to people who were renting
their places, in order to
make that experience better,
because everything starts from
looking at the photos where
you're going to be staying.
And the app really
reflects their philosophy
by focusing so much on photos,
and even just little things
like this little snappy way to
go through photos real quickly.
And obviously it carries
through in the full-screen view.
It's super important.
You don't know how
important it is,
moving towards that kind of
interaction versus having
a typical, maybe, obsolete
gallery where you have to keep
on going back and forth within
the photos that are provided
to you.
That makes the whole difference.
ABHILASH KUDUVALLI:
Yeah, I think
the other thing for me, as
someone that's used Airbnb
quite a lot, is how functional
in feature this app is.
I thought you could just browse
listings, make a booking.
But you can create a listing so
easily, it kind of makes sense.
You have your mobile device.
You choose your number of rooms.
You take photos.
It does it really nicely.
So I feel like there's
a lot of screens
that they put a lot of
effort into designing well.
So that's the other thing
that stood out for me.
MARCO PAGLIA: Yeah,
even the dialogues
with renters and
the chat system,
it feels almost
like it could have
been an application in itself by
how beautifully it's designed,
and by the level of
details they had,
like the profiles of the house.
Everything is very,
very well curated.
You feel welcome in
their application.
NICK BUTCHER: So
moving on, the next app
that we would like to
cover is a heart rate
monitor from Runtastic.
And so this is an excellent
example of what we're always
talking about on Android
Design in Action,
is to take the holo
design language
and use that as
your starting point,
and really bring
your own personality
and your own branding
to the equation.
So I think they've done an
excellent job of interpreting
the raw holo design language and
doing that-- so simple things
like the way they've
recolored a bunch of elements,
and the use of the
typographic styles
we commonly use, like the
block capitals, when to use,
and robust or light
or larger-set text
to bring emphasis
to certain elements.
I think they've done a really,
really nice job of doing that.
The one screen I
would like to call out
as being extremely
beautifully is the hero screen
of application, which
is when you're actually
using the application to
measure your heart beat.
So if you haven't used the app,
it's pretty innovative really.
It actually fires up your
camera and the flashlight
on the back of your phone,
and actually shines the light
through your finger and
measures the difference in color
to actually measure
the heart rate, which
is pretty innovative.
But if we look at it now,
when it's doing that,
it uses this
beautiful blur effect
to indicate when it's
picked up your heart beat.
And you have this live graph
going along the bottom, which
will show you you're going
to get an instant response.
It's doing something
that's trying to find it.
And it's just a really,
really beautifully,
well-designed experience to
communicate what it's doing,
which is pretty novel.
[INAUDIBLE]
So that was Heart Rate Pro.
Does anyone have
anything to add?
MARCO PAGLIA: Just a
little simple thing.
Even the dialogues
are personalized.
They have a strong web
collar on top of dialogues.
I think they use all caps.
They use the font,
with a different size--
different from the very
typical out-of-the-box dialogue
framework that we have.
And I think it's something
that we invited developers
to play with, as long as the
interaction would be the same.
It feels novel, but it
doesn't feel completely
different from everything
within our platform.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, it feels
completely native Android,
but it feels completely
Runtastic at the same time,
right?
It's that good marriage of both.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah, definitely.
So the net app that
we want to talk about
is called The Whole Pantry.
And we've already talked
about the importance
of high-quality photos
and photography,
and the impact that
can make on your app,
obviously depending
on the kind of app.
But for The Whole Pantry,
they use beautiful photos
to really sell the entire
purpose of their app, which
is to present a very holistic
approach to nutrition,
lifestyle.
They've got recipes.
They have health guides.
They have recommended
products and services.
We can drill in here and
look at macadamia and caramel
cheesecake.
The photos are very
high resolution.
I think the app itself is
a 75-megabyte download.
So it's definitely
in the forefront
of the app presentation.
MARCO PAGLIA: And I
can't stress enough
how important having the
right resolution for assets
and for photos is.
I think The Whole Pantry, on a
tablet like [INAUDIBLE], really
defines a beautiful experience,
because the photos are so much
high res, and unfortunately
something we don't see enough
out there, because
they're expensive,
et cetera, et cetera.
But when you see it, you
know that it is important.
So I'm actually very
much looking forward
to seeing bandwidth
getting faster, and seeing
more and more high-resolution
photos in a large-form factor,
because it defines
the experience
in a whole new light.
ABHILASH KUDUVALLI:
Yeah, I've tried
a few of these recipe apps--
not that I cook or anything.
But they've put a lot of
effort into curating it,
and they've slowly released
updates to recipes.
So you can see with
the recipes they
have, there's nothing
that looks broken.
Every photo is amazing.
The ingredients,
the instructions--
they're all nicely done.
So it doesn't rely on
trying to render something
from a junky website.
They've tried to keep
it within the app.
NICK BUTCHER:
Especially food porn.
It's just like
everything looks amazing
MARCO PAGLIA: Anything
here like we saw in Circa,
I'd like to make people pay
attention to the different font
style in the action bar.
Which really, those
small differences
will make your application
different from the rest.
And Circa had different fonts.
Whole Pantry has this
italic serif-type of font.
It really makes the
application stand out
with a very simple change.
You don't have to do
a custom action bar
or go crazy with things.
You just need to curate your
application with a very small
difference, and it really
stands out from the crowd.
MIKE DENNY: Yes, so the next
app we want to talk about
is Tumblr.
ROMAN NURIK: Yes, so the
thing about Tumblr-- Tumblr
in itself, I think everybody
knows what Tumblr is.
It's kind of a micro-blogging
platform, I guess.
The thing I want to focus on
for Tumblr, the app itself,
is not so much see the actual
experience of using Tumblr,
but it's the onboarding-- the
first time you run the app.
And we had a whole episode
of Android Design in Action
just on this, because
it's so very important.
When you get featured
on Google Play,
or when you're in a collection
like the Beautiful Design
Collection, a lot of people are
just discovering your brand.
And they're coming to
your app, and just kind
of getting a feel
for what it is.
So you don't want to throw up
a login now or register now
type dialogue.
You want to give them
a taste of what they're
going to get when they
sign up, if they sign up.
And so Tumblr does
this brilliantly.
They go above and beyond.
You can obviously view public
Tumblr content in the app,
I guess in the explorer tab.
But you can even
start following.
You can even start
personalizing the app
before you even have an account.
Obviously once you follow
more than ten Tumblr blogs,
they'll say hey,
you probably should
start saving this
somewhere, because this
is just kind of stored locally.
And as soon as you, I
guess, sign in or sign up,
they actually add
that to your account.
So it's just done
very brilliantly.
Besides that, obviously
the UI's very clean.
Again, the content stands out.
The Chrome is
almost transparent.
It's there.
There are the icons
there and the text,
but it's really the
content that stands out.
But to me, the number
one thing in this app
is the amazing
onboarding experience.
ABHILASH KUDUVALLI:
Yeah, I mean there's
a few little nice animations.
Like when you follow
something for the first time
in the explorer tab, and it
flies into your home tab,
it's just a nice
little indication.
The pull-to-refresh, even like
how the radio menu comes out--
yeah, there's quite
a few nice touches.
NICK BUTCHER: OK,
so the next app
that we would like to
talk about is Umano.
So Umano is a news
consumption application,
but it's kind of different to
Circa and other standard ones
in that it's all
orientated around listening
to the news, having the news
read out to you, spoken to you.
And so one of the
things I very much like
about this application
is they have
quite a complex
information hierarchy,
but it's expressed
very, very clearly,
using some very familiar
Android patterns.
So they used the drawer for
the major organizational tasks,
as it were.
But they also have this partial
width and swipeable tabs,
to allow you to filter
down by categories
and really find the
content you're looking for.
Another interaction
which I really like
is they've learned from
the best, as it were,
and they've done a very similar
implementation to Google Play
Music, to allow you to see
what you're currently listening
to you while navigating around,
to find the next story you
might want to listen to.
So here at the bottom, I
have a Now Playing drawer.
And I can drag it up
or just tap on it,
and quickly get back to
the current story which
is now playing, so I can quickly
go in and rewind a minute,
or add it to a favorite
playlist or something like that.
And it works very nicely.
You can see as you drag up,
it just kind of replaces
the content behind it and acts
similar to the action bar.
MARCO PAGLIA: It's beautiful
how the action bar moves away
together, with a sort of
parallax effect, as the view is
coming up.
It's a very , very nice detail.
MIKE DENNY: And one of the
main use cases of this app
is to listen to the news
during your commute, right?
So they've actually added
something particular for use
in the car.
ABHILASH KUDUVALLI:
Do you want to talk?
MARCO PAGLIA: No.
ABHILASH KUDUVALLI:
Basically when
you're listening to something,
when it starts playing you
can switch into car mode
by tapping the car icon.
And they've just
done a beautiful job
of presenting a UI that's
very touch-friendly when
you don't have a
lot of attention.
There's a nice overlay.
There's a remote control view.
It's just a nice touch.
NICK BUTCHER:
Easy-to-hit buttons.
ABHILASH KUDUVALLI: Very easy
to hit buttons while driving.
MARCO PAGLIA: They used the
new framework from KitKat,
where the view goes full-screen.
And how it fades in and
out is really [INAUDIBLE].
This is an application that
tries to make something
that we've got used to, which
is hearing things being read
out loud by our machines,
but it makes it more human,
bringing human beings
back into the game.
So obviously there's a
focus in design on humanity,
if you wish, across the
app visually, and even
from the audio perspective.
NICK BUTCHER: And the
[INAUDIBLE] developers,
I know that they've
open-sourced their drag-up panel
implementation as well.
So if you have a similar
kind of interaction,
you might want to look at that.
MIKE DENNY: Awesome.
So the next app that
we want to talk about
is perhaps slightly
controversial.
I know that when the
app was first released
there was a flurry of discussion
about it, and that is Yahoo!
Weather.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, so I want
to spend a little bit of time
talking about some of
awesome details in Yahoo!
Weather.
Now again, all these apps
are not without their flaws,
but here we really
want to highlight
some of the best details.
So Yahoo!
Weather, when you
first open it up,
it just shows you, obviously,
the weather near where you are.
Now front and center-- I guess
back and center-- is a photo.
And this photo is actually
highly contextual.
The photo is not only about
the current weather type--
whether it be sunny or
rainy-- but it's also
contextual in the sense that
it shows you the location.
So I think that if you're in
London and it's super sunny,
it'll show you London
when it's sunny.
But if it's rainy-- [LAUGHTER]
ROMAN NURIK: But the idea's
that it's highly contextual,
so it actually gets you a
pretty good feel of what
it may actually
look like outside.
Now in terms of the UI itself,
if you have multiple locations
set up, you can swipe
left and right, obviously,
between your current location
and your predetermined
locations.
And there's a nice parallax
effect where the background
image actually scrolls
at a slower rate,
and it kind of
transitions neatly
into the next image
for the next location.
But within a specific location
as you start scrolling down,
that background image
actually starts to blur.
And this blurs so
that you can actually
focus on the information
that's in the foreground--
things like the forecast and
the details of the weather.
And then if you scroll
down to the very bottom,
this is probably my
favorite detail in this app.
You get to these really
awesome animations
of wind and sunlight.
And it's these really
small, little touches
that really set this app
apart from other weather apps.
So I really like a lot of these
different touches in there.
Those are my favorite elements.
NICK BUTCHER: One of
my favorite things
as well is as you're
scrolling down
to see some of the more
detailed information,
I love that it synchronizes
the scroll position.
So that if you
swipe horizontally,
you can easily
compare two locations.
So if you're trying to decide on
you want to go to either City X
or Y this weekend,
you can scroll down
to the long-range forecast
and easily pan between them
and have these comparisons.
Little details like that
just show how much thought's
gone into that.
MARCO PAGLIA: Yeah,
it really shows
how design follows
functions after all.
And all these details
we're seeing ,
they're not just to make the
application more beautiful,
but even more functional.
And they create a story
that is understandable.
To those details that
Roman was talking about,
that information at the bottom,
also when you pull it down,
you have this pull-to-refresh.
They have this little
sun spinning around.
So a lot of little
playful elements
that they embed
in the application
that make it fun and surprising.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah, so we
definitely love the Yahoo!
Weather app.
Speaking of visual design when
compared to interaction design,
the next app that we
want to talk about
is Etsy, where it's
just a gorgeous app that
screams their own brand.
It very loudly has a voice.
And it's interesting because
visually you might not
recognize Android
glyphs or icons.
They've got a lot
of custom things.
But the interaction
design, the design patterns
for navigation
throughout the app
are very consistent
with platform standards.
And that means that
users will instantly
feel at home using
the app, while still
being exposed to Etsy's brand.
ABHILASH KUDUVALLI:
Yeah, I think
Marco mentioned
earlier dialogues.
And again, Etsy, the
custom dialogues they use,
I really like.
And the other thing I
liked is the purchase flow.
I feel like a lot of apps, once
you get into the purchase flow,
they kind of get into web views,
or they're not as well done.
But these guys, again, have
paid a lot of attention
to the purchase flows through
the app, which is important.
MARCO PAGLIA: For
us it's amazing how,
when we define certain rules
for the UI-- like the new side
drawer and things like
that-- how good developers
and good designers,
they go above and beyond
to play with that simple
rule, but to make it special.
We have seen it
before on Airbnb.
But if you pay attention when
you bring the side drawer in,
your view zooms back.
And if you look
into Etsy instead,
when you pull the drawer
in, the view fades.
So there are a lot
of little effects.
And again, it's what
I was saying before.
Just changing the font
in your action bar,
but keeping the action bar
as it is from an interaction
point of view, or
changing the effects
when the drawer comes in, is
enough to really distinguish
your application from
the rest of the crowd.
In this case, Etsy also
made their site navigation
to be very colorful.
Also here to be noted
is the different font.
Treatment for the side drawer,
for the action bar as well.
A lot of elements that I
invite everybody to play with.
NICK BUTCHER: And we're
not showing it right here,
but this app is
[INAUDIBLE] responsive.
So if you try it on all manner
of different size and shape
devices, they use this very
flexible staggered grid layout,
which they kind of change
between different columns
and so on, just to maintain
the same aspect ratio,
but to fill up the
space beautifully.
So while they do maintain great
use of white space and so on,
they really just fill
up available room
to make the most
on other devices.
I guess it's
stretched experience.
ABHILASH KUDUVALLI:
Have they open-sourced?
NICK BUTCHER:
They've open-sourced
that staggered
grid view as well.
MARCO PAGLIA: If I remember
correctly, even the dialogues,
they bring a nice surprise
to the experience.
They don't simply pop.
They don't simply fade in
the middle of the screen.
They actually come
from the back,
from the bottom of the screen.
It just creates more of
a metaphor about where
these dialogues are coming from.
And it's definitely
a nice touch.
MIKE DENNY: Definitely.
So this has been a look at the
Winter 2013 Beautiful Design
Collection.
We hope you enjoyed watching it.
And until next time,
I'm Mike Denny.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye
from me, Nick Butcher.
MARCO PAGLIA: Bye.
This is Marco.
See you next time.
ABHILASH KUDUVALLI: See you.
It's Abhilash.
ROMAN NURIK: And see you
guys later from New York.
It's Roman.